all right just in time for summer a
brand new fitness area is opening later
this morning at craig ranch park in
north las vegas mary jen mary jane
belliesa joins us live from this free
outdoor fitness slot mary jane looks
like it's a lot of fun out there show us
more
oh yeah you know sherry we've been out
here all morning at the fitness lot of
craig ranch park and it's all thanks to
a partnership between the city of north
las vegas and aarp to make exercise a
little bit more accessible you know
we've been out here and actually we're
joined by joy craney she woke up early
and came down to the park and joy you
know you have a really incredible story
because you've been utilizing this park
to work out and exercise and even more
so now with this new equipment
yeah i love coming out to the park i
have eight children nine the ninth one
on the way
and coming out here doing my pull-ups
walking the track has been keeping me
fit for over ten years and i can't
believe it when you said that you are
pregnant right now you are literally
doing a couple push-ups i can't even do
that you're putting me to shame and so
you know it's amazing now that they put
this together because that means more
people can come out here and enjoy it
such as yourself yeah yeah and a lot of
people even children come out here they
play around and you know it's
encouraging the community to get more
fit and be healthy so i love it and what
do you think of the new equipment that's
out here it's really nice it's very
versatile i've seen
elders out here doing low impact work
and i've seen young people running in
circles and you know doing pull-ups just
like i enjoyed doing so well we got to
get a shot of you doing some pull-ups
because that's incredible i can't even
do one you're over here knocking them
out left and right and it's not easy to
do she's got her gloves ready look at
that can you believe it folks eight kids
with one on the way she's pregnant right
now i couldn't even believe it that is
amazing
you are an inspiration right there and
you know what the city of north las
vegas and arp they're getting ready to
put together a ceremony at 8 00 a.m so
come on down and you can enjoy all the
equipment here just like joy as well
reporting live at craig bench park mary
jane valliosa live local now